Rusia fue el primer país del mundo en crear
una vacuna contra el CoronaVirus, la llamada
Sputnik V. Rusia se ha adelantado a toda la
industria farmacéutica mundial. Y con esta
vacuna surge el debate ¿Podemos fiarnos de
la tecnología médica rusa? Muchos países
piensan que no.
Brasil rechaza la Sputnik V y Moscú culpa
a EE.UU.
Y Brasil no es el único país. Ni la Unió
Europea ni Estados Unidos han aprobado esta
vacuna. La pregunta es ¿Por qué desconfían
de esta vacuna? ¿Hay razones médicas o es
simple y llanamente una cuestión ideológica?
¡No sólo eso! La vacuna rusa genera muchas
más incógnitas. Por ejemplo… esta.
Putin apoya que Rusia renuncie a la patente
de su vacuna de covid
Pensadlo bien ¿Por qué Putin querría renunciar
a la patente de su propia vacuna? A fin de
cuentas, Rusia podría ganar una fortuna vendiendo
su vacuna a todo el mundo. Al final del vídeo
responderemos a esta pregunta.
Mientras tanto, la gran duda que tendréis
muchos es… ¿De verdad funciona la Sputnik
V o es, simplemente, una maniobra de propaganda
rusa? En Visualpolitik no somos expertos en
vacunas, así que nos fiamos de lo que dicen
revistas científicas como la británica The
Lancet. En febrero de 2020, The Lancet publicó
un estudio con 20.000 participantes. Demostraron
que la vacuna tiene una eficacia del 91.6%.
Es decir, que sí, todo apunta a que la vacuna
rusa funciona.
Sin embargo, hoy en día, solo hay 64 países
que la han aprobado. La mayoría están en
Latinoamérica, Oriente Medio y África. Los
países más ricos del mundo siguen sin fiarse
de la medicina rusa. Y todo esto puede ser
muy sospechoso. A fin de cuentas, la Sputnik
V fue la primera vacuna en ser anunciada.
En agosto de 2020, cuando todo el mundo estaba
desesperado por encontrar una vacuna, Rusia
presentó su candidata. Varios meses después,
tanto Europa como Estados Unidos siguen discutiendo
si deberían empezar a utilizarla o no. Muchos
pensaréis que hay un doble rasero. A fin
de cuentas, la vacuna de Pfizer-Biontech y
la de Moderna se aprobaron a las pocas semanas
de anunciarse ¿Cuál es el problema con la
vacuna rusa? ¿Por qué tanta gente desconfía
de ella? ¿Hablamos de ciencia o de política
pura y dura? ¿Cómo es posible que Rusia
se haya adelantado al mundo entero? ¿Y por
qué Putin quiere renunciar a la patente?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
MADE IN RUSSIA
La primera pregunta que os estaréis haciendo
todos es…
¿De dónde viene el nombre SPUTNIK V? Sputnik
significa “compañero de viaje”. Les recuerda
a los mejores momentos de Rusia y por eso,
la agencia de noticias internacional rusa
también se llama Sputnik news… y la vacuna
que Rusia quiere vender al mundo se llama
la SPUTNIK V. La V es de Vacuna.
Y diréis ¿Pero de verdad la ciencia rusa
es tan importante como parece? Y lo cierto
es que sí. Por ejemplo ¿Sabéis quién creó
el primer reactor nuclear del mundo? Pues
no, no fueron científicos estadounidenses
sino Ígor Kurchatov, un científico ruso.
Y no es el único, Rusia ha dado a muchos
de los mejores científicos de la historia.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos…
¿Cómo es posible? ¿No se supone que la
URSS era Mordor? ¿De repente el comunismo
funciona?
La ventaja de tener una economía centralizada
es que, si el estado decide invertir en una
tecnología, puede poner un montón de dinero
de golpe. Lo hacían con el comunismo y lo
hacen con Putin. Por eso el armamento ruso
es tan bueno: como los misiles S-400 que están
al mismo nivel que sus equivalentes en Estados
Unidos.
Y eso ocurrió con el Instituto GAMALEYA.
Recordad bien su nombre, porque es el desarrollador
de la vacuna rusa Sputnik V, un instituto
fundado en 1891 y nacionalizado en 1919. En
Occidente no se sabía mucho de este centro
público ¡Y no os culpo! Pues Rusia no es
destacada por dar a conocer sus actividades.
Cuando las farmacéuticas capitalistas se
preocupaban por otros medicamentos más comerciales
y no por las vacunas, Gamaleya ya investigaba
vacunas para virus que asolan el tercer mundo
como el Ébola. Curar el Ébola en África
es poco rentable para una empresa privada.
Pero Gamaleya no busca el beneficio económico.
Y eso les ha dado ventaja competitiva. Economía
estatal 1, economía de mercado 0. JAQUE MATE,
NEOLIBERALES
Lo mismo pasa con el dinero. Al ser una economía
tan centralizada, el estado tiene mucho dinero
para ponerlo donde hace falta ¿Qué han hecho?
Para esto entra en escena una persona con
el respaldo total del Kremlin, atentos a este
personaje:
Él es Kirill Dmitriev, Ucraniano, de 45 años,
estudió en las universidades más prestigiosas
de Estados Unidos, pero ahora se estableció
con el bando opuesto y es CEO del Fondo Soberano
Ruso. Al igual que Noruega tiene su fondo
soberano, Rusia también tiene uno aunque
más pequeño. Aun así, es lo suficientemente
grande como para invertir 10.000 millones
de dólares para desarrollar la vacuna que
el mundo entero está esperando.
“Estados Unidos se sobresaltó al oír zumbar
al Sputnik. Va a ocurrir lo mismo con esta
vacuna. Rusia va a llegar primero”
-Kirill Dmitriev, CEO del Fondo Ruso de Inversión
Directa
Con tanto dinero, tantos años, y sumado con
el optimismo de este personaje, no es casualidad
que en agosto de 2020 ocurriera esto.
Putin asegura que Rusia tiene la primera vacuna
aprobada contra la covid-19
El 11 de agosto, Sputnik fue la primera vacuna
autorizada en todo el planeta para uso de
emergencia, esta aprobación se dio por parte
del gobierno ruso, en base a los estudios
de las primeras dos fases publicados por The
Lancet, ¿Creeis que todo el mundo vería
con buenos ojos esta autorización? Pues ¡Claro
que no! Esta fue una decisión criticada por
muchos, pues aún faltaba los datos finales
de los ensayos. ahí iniciaron una serie de
dudas. ¿Cómo es posible que Rusia pudiera
sacar una vacuna antes que otros países como
Estados Unidos o Reino Unido?
Y es que en ese momento, nadie se fiaba de
la vacuna. Ni siquiera nosotros en VisualPolitik.
Pero, a medida que se hicieron pruebas se
descubrió que la vacuna funcionaba ¡No sólo
eso! Es más barata que las demás, a 10 dólares
la dosis, en comparación, esto es un 60%
más barata que la de Moderna y 50% más barata
que la de Pfizer. Es decir: misma eficacia
pero precios más bajos y, sobretodo, logística
más barata. En otras palabras: la Sputnik
V es la vacuna más competitiva. Rusia podría
comerse el mercado internacional.
Sin embargo… Putin está a favor de renunciar
a la patente. Es decir, que cualquiera en
cualquier parte del mundo podría fabricar
esta vacuna sin tener que pagar al Instituto
Gamaleya. Y diréis ¿Por qué Rusia quiere
renunciar a tanto dinero? Vamos a responder
a esta pregunta más adelante. Pero antes,
tenemos que entender el auténtico problema
de la vacuna rusa.
LA OTRA CARA DE UNA ECONOMÍA CENTRALIZADA
La pregunta que todos os estaréis haciendo
ahora es ¿Cómo han podido fabricar vacunas
tan rápido? Si seguís VisualPolitik, ya
sabéis que no basta con tener una buena fórmula
para crear una vacuna. También hay que fabricarla.
Y eso es un proceso realmente complicado.
Para que os hagáis una idea, a finales de
2020, una empresa tan grande como PFIZER decía
que eran capaces de fabricar solamente 1100
millones de dosis a lo largo de este año
2021. De hecho, las campañas de vacunación
se han ralentizado en Europa por la falta
de suministros. Entonces ¿Cómo es posible
que Rusia haya podido producir vacunas para
sus casi 144 millones de habitantes y puedan
exportar tan rápido? Respuesta rápida: no,
no pueden fabricar tantas vacunas.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en el momento
en el que hacemos este vídeo, Rusia sólo
tiene a un 6% de la población vacunada. Por
comparar,
Isarel tiene el 56% de población vacunada,
Estados Unidos 35%, y la Unión Europea se
encuentra con un 11%. ¿Cómo es posible entonces
que Rusia esté tan preocupada por vender
vacunas cuando todavía no tiene ni para su
propia población? Pues bien, esta es la primera
gran duda que tienen muchos. Atentos.
“Seguimos preguntándonos por qué Rusia
ofrece, teóricamente, millones y millones
de dosis mientras no avanza lo suficiente
en la vacunación de su propio pueblo”,
--
Ursula von der Leyen, presidenta de la Comisión
Europea
Como os podéis imaginar, la propaganda rusa
vende esto como que Europa tiene prejuicios
contra los rusos. Sin embargo, muchos países
europeos han negociado compras de vacunas
rusas por su cuenta. Y, creedme, en este caso,
la ideología y los prejuicios tienen muy
poco que ver. Atentos.
Isabel Díaz Ayuso, presidenta de la Comunidad
de Madrid, seguirá negociando la compra de
la vacuna rusa para acelerar la inmunidad
de Madrid
Los que veáis este vídeo desde España ya
conocéis a Isabel Díaz Ayuso. Acaba de salir
reelegida en unas elecciones donde su eslogan
era “Comunismo o Libertad”. Si hay una
política que podría tener fobias contra
Rusia y todo lo que representa, esa es Ayuso.
Sin embargo, en lo que a vacunas respecta,
la ideología les importa muy poco.
¡Pero no sólo hablamos de negociaciones!
Hay países que ha pasado de las palabras
a los hechos. Uno de ellos es Eslovaquia.
Eslovaquia, segundo país de la Unión Europea
en recibir la Sputnik V
Y aquí es donde llegan los problemas. Sobre
el papel, la Sputnik es una vacuna fantástica.
Pero cuando Eslovaquia analizó las 200.000
dosis entregadas por Rusia, llegaron a esta
conclusión.
“Estas vacunas… lo único que tienen en
común (con la fórmula original) es el nombre”
– Instituto Estatal de Control de Medicamentos
(SUKL)
En otras palabras (((MEME ALIEXPRESS))) “Cuando
lo pides al Instituto Gamaleya vs. “Cuando
te llega”.
Para que os hagáis una idea… este incidente
de la vacuna ha sido una bomba política en
Eslovaquia. De hecho, el Primer Ministro Eslovaco
tuvo que dimitir por las críticas recibidas
por comprar la vacuna rusa. Ha sido un auténtico
fracaso de su gobierno. Además, las autoridades
sanitarias de este país se quejan de que
apenas les han enviado información sobre
la vacuna.
Y aquí es donde llegamos a la otra cara de
la economía centralizada. Lo que podríamos
llamar el “efecto Chernobyl”. Es cierto,
el Estado Ruso puede pagar una fortuna a sus
institutos estatales para que desarrollen
la vacuna ¿Pero quién la fabrica? Aquí
es cuando entra un concepto clave en economía:
“La cadena de valor”. Es decir, un científico
puede descubrir una fórmula perfecta para
fabricar vacunas. Pero para fabricarla necesitas
de cientos de empresas: fábricas de vacunas,
proveedores, empresas de logística. Hablamos
de una red enorme de empresas interconectadas.
Desde el estado se pueden imponer controles
de calidad pero es casi imposible crear toda
esa red de proveedores desde cero. Y cuando
se hace, suele salir mal. De hecho, eso es
exactamente lo que ocurrió con el accidente
de Chernobyl. Chernobyl tenía una tecnología
puntera. Ya os digo que los físicos nucleares
soviéticos no tenían nada que envidiar a
los estadounidenses. Sin embargo había dos
problemas. El primero es que los reactores
no estaban pensados para uso civil sino militar.
El segundo era la puesta en práctica. Para
abaratar costes, los constructores de la central
se saltaron unos cuantos controles de calidad
(por cierto, gracias a Operador Nuclear por
asesorarme en esta parte. Le podéis seguir
en Twitter por aquí). Y diréis ¿Nadie se
dio cuenta? Pues probablemente sí. Pero ¿Quién
se atreve a decirle al político de turno
que ha tomado una mala decisión si eso le
puede llevar a la cárcel? cárcel? Si algo
caracteriza a las dictaduras es la falta de
transparencia. Y eso significa procesos poco
eficientes. En algunos casos, esto se traduce
en sobrecostes y falta de competitividad pero
en el caso de Chernobyl supuso la catástrofe
que todos conocemos.
Así que volvemos a la pregunta de antes ¿Cómo
es posible que Rusia haya sido capaz de fabricar
tantas vacunas en tan poco tiempo? Y la respuesta
es: no, Rusia no tiene una industria farmacéutica
capaz de fabricar vacunas en masa. Pero, a
la vez, quiere vender vacunas al mercado internacional
¿Conclusión? Muchas de las dosis que se
han vendido no han pasado todos los controles
de calidad necesarios. Sucedió en Eslovaquia
y podría suceder en otros países.
Dicho de otra forma: hay un océano de diferencia
entre “lo que pides al Instituto Gamaleya”
y “lo que te llega”.
¡Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos!
¡Ya están de nuevo los de VisualPolitik
criticando a Rusia! ¿Quién os ha pagado
para hacer este vídeo? Pues no, tranquilos,
ahora viene la parte realmente buena de la
vacuna rusa.
POR QUÉ RUSIA NO QUIERE PATENTES
Sputnik es la única vacuna que cuenta con
su propia página web y su perfil en Twitter.
La última de las armas del Kremlin para promover
la confianza en su vacuna, y funcionó, pues
los datos no mienten:
“Argentina recibe nuevo cargamento de vacunas
Sputnik V, suma en total 4,38 millones de
dosis contra COVID”.
“Llega a la India el primer lote de la vacuna
rusa Sputnik V”
Pero Fonseca, ¿Por qué compran Sputnik y
no otras vacunas? La respuesta se resume en
dos palabras: ideología y necesidad. Tanto
Argentina como India tienen lazos ideológicos
y culturales con Rusia. Pero de eso hablaremos
en otro vídeo. Lo cierto es que, tanto India
como Argentina no pueden comprar las vacunas
caras de Pfizer y Moderna. Además, casi toda
la producción de estas empresas ya está
vendida a los países ricos ¿Conclusión?
La vacuna rusa les viene como anillo al dedo.
En varios estudios se ha demostrado que funciona.
Y existe incluso un caso de éxito real. Un
país que parece haber acabado ya con la pandemia
gracias a la ayuda del Kremlin ¿A qué país
me refiero? Atentos.
San Marino, primer país de Europa en vencer
la Covid-19 con Sputnik V
Pensadlo bien: hablamos de un microestado
de tan solo 34 mil personas. Es decir, que
es relativamente fácil fabricar vacunas para
toda su población sin necesidad de tener
grandes empresas farmacéuticas. En el momento
en el que hacemos este vídeo, el 90% de la
población de San Marino ya está vacunada.
Y no han tenido ni una sola muerte desde el
27 de abril.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos:
es posible fabricar vacunas en un microestado.
Incluso se pueden poner controles de calidad
para un lote de 60.000 vacunas ¿Pero qué
pasa cuando hablamos de países grandes como
Argentina o la India? ¿De verdad es posible
que Rusia garantice la calidad de millones
de vacunas? ¿Cómo lo van a hacer? Pues atentos.
AstraZeneca y el instituto Gamaleya firmaron
un memorándum de cooperación con el objetivo
de hacer uso de todas las posibilidades de
cooperación internacional para acercar la
victoria sobre la infección.
En otras palabras: Rusia pone la ciencia y
Atrazeneca las fábricas. Y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando en este momento: ¿AstraZeneca?
Pero… ¿No tienen su propia vacuna? ¿Por
qué querrían desarrollar las vacunas de
otros? Pues sí, tenéis razón. AstraZeneca
va a fabricar ambas vacunas: la suya y la
de Rusia. Y esto no es suficiente para que
Moscú pueda distribuir su vacuna en países
tan grandes como la India.
Y aquí llega la respuesta a la pregunta del
principio ¿Por qué Rusia está dispuesta
a renunciar a su patente? Pues por esto.
Rusia e India pactan producir 200 millones
de vacunas Sputnik V al año
Rusia está buscando producir su vacuna en
masa. Y para eso necesita asociarse con cuantas
más farmacéuticas como sea posible. No hablamos
de grandes nombres como PFIZER sino de empresas
dedicadas a la fabricación de medicamentos
genéricos. En China ya hay acuerdos con empresas
para producir 260 millones de vacunas. En
Argentina, los laboratorios Richmond producirán
100 millones de dosis.
Como os podéis imaginar, si Rusia regala
la patente o la pone a un precio muy barato,
será más fácil encontrar empresas que la
fabriquen. Sobre todo en los países de renta
más baja. A cambio, el Kremlin va a tener
más influencia en zonas como Latinoamérica
o la India. Pero eso
sería un tema más complejo para desarrollar
en otro vídeo.
En lo que a salud pública respecta, la vacuna
rusa puede ser una muy buena noticia para
todos. Ahora bien, su efectividad va a depender
mucho de quién la fabrique. Habrá países
y laboratorios con mejores controles de calidad
que otros. Así que muy probablemente, veremos
países donde la Sputnik sirve para acabar
con la pandemia rápidamente y países donde
haya problemas. En cualquier caso, todo esto
son suposiciones. Ahora llega el turno para
vosotros ¿Creéis que la Unión Europea y
Estados Unidos terminarán aprobando la vacuna
rusa? ¿En qué medida puede servir esta vacuna
para aumentar la influencia de Rusia en el
mundo? Podéis dejarme la respuesta en los
comentarios.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí, en
VisualPolitik, sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribíos al canal
y dadle a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el
próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto.